joining me now newt gingrich former
speaker of the house
and fox news contributor he's the author
of trump and the american future
it's always great to speak to you
speaker gingrich someone i consider a
mentor and who as you can see i've been
following around since i was 13 years
old
oh my god do you remember that i don't
think i'd ever seen that before
yes that's amazing
i want to talk to you about this goal
that we have
in this country of getting back to doing
great things
and as you know i feel like this is
something that
really ought to unite us it ought to
bring us together it ought to inspire us
each as americans
what can we do to get back to that point
well you know one of the greatnesses of
the american system
is that government is in the end not at
the center of our being
we're not the soviet union we're not
communist china we're not uh
cuba we are despite every effort of the
left
we are still a free people and you can
see that in space
the greatest breakthroughs in space
right now are coming from
two or three entrepreneurs and they're
just doing it in fact
unless the biden administration finds a
way to
[ __ ] them uh they're almost certainly
going to take us to the moon
and they're almost certainly going to
take us to mars and
you you're going to find your family
having the option i think uh
by the time uh that they are
20 25 years old to be able to
consider seriously uh going to mars now
these are not small things and it's
taken it's ironic for
people who sometimes complain about
immigration
elon musk is one of the great
contributors to america's future
uh and he does it because it it fills
his ego needs
uh he didn't fill out a form for the
government the government has funded
some of his projects
but he's undertaken things nobody
thought possible
i also think that we have to look at you
know if you wanted a really great goal
for america
it would be to decide that every
american
was truly going to have the ability to
pursue happiness
and that would require overhauling the
schools it would require providing
physical safety
in our biggest cities it would require
changing the tax law
to make it very easy to run a small
business but
if we took it seriously roll up our
sleeves my guess is within a decade
we would be a dramatically different
country than we are right now
speaker i feel like we need to be on
more of a cold war footing
when it comes to our relationship with
china they have
undertaken a war against us in terms of
sending fentanyl over that has
killed so many americans we see their
support in alaska
of the type of of race-based politics
that are designed to split us apart
internally what can we do to achieve
more of a cold war mindset about our
relationship with china
in a time when so many people seem to be
compromised
by it at the highest levels of of
corporate america and of government
well we're right now exactly where we
were between 1945 and 19.
groups of the out of world war ii we
didn't want to have a cold war
we didn't want to have the soviet union
as an adversary but they gave us no
choice
and over time we gradually toughened up
we gradually created institutions to
contain them
now i'll give you a very simple example
a bill has been introduced to allow
people to sue china
over covet but of course everyone knows
even if you won the lawsuit they
wouldn't pay anything
we should establish a 30 tariff on all
chinese goods
so that we could build a trust fund and
pay off the
enormous debt that china owes the united
states and
i'd recommend every country in the world
impose a 30
tariff because the truth is uh the
chinese caused
what was the chinese virus trump was
right uh all this political correctness
is nonsense
the chinese lied to and manipulated the
world health organization
the chinese bear the responsibility for
allowing this virus to get out of
control
and they say they have to be real things
this is not about words when we were
faced with the soviet union
we built a strategic air command the
central intelligence agency
we created the modern air force we
created nato
to protect europe uh sito to protect
southeast asia
we were deeply engaged in real things
and xi jinping's not stupid and so we do
real things that have a real impact he's
just
gonna think it's just a bunch of
politicians over here prattling
and he'll figure that he he can
influence
most of them and own a few of them i i
think
uh mr speaker that we have a situation
now where unfortunately
our we have so many politicians who are
asleep at the wheel on this
uh and are not paying attention to how
important it is for the future of the
country
thank you so much for joining me this
evening thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else